let's just bring some brick knees we're  getting from the the French news agency  AFP that a vehicle it seems is plowed  into a crowd in Nice in the South of  France they're saying in an apparent  attack with several hurt this is  according to officials and witnesses now  certainly video that we have seen at the  veracity of which we cannot verify show  people running along the the famous  promenade des anglais in something of a  panic other video and pictures show  emergency crews at the scene and some  suggestion that some people have been  hurt as I say we cannot verify this  footage but certainly the AFP news  agency now talking about a vehicle that  is plowed into a crowd in Nice during  the 14th of July Bastille Day  celebrations and fireworks down there  they're saying in an apparent attack now  that is hard to verify at the moment but  several hurt now according to officials  and witnesses we would of course bring  you more on that story as we get it